well hello they are watching the press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages
in the next half hour or so then we will
see what's making the headlines
with christopher hope chief political
correspondent
at the daily telegraph and alison morris
columnist
at the belfast telegraph great to see
both of you as ever we turn our
attention
first of all to the front pages starting
with the telegraph
which leads with the confusion from the
government today
on whether or not people may travel to
areas where cases of the
indian variant of chronovirus are high
that is also on the front page of the i
their headline
number 10 cancels accidental lockdowns
and that is also the main story for the
guardian anger
forces climb down over travel
restrictions
britain is heading for record-breaking
vaccination numbers
over the next fortnight according to the
times as all
over 30s will be offered a jab
airlines have changed their flight paths
to avoid bella russian airspace after
authorities in belarus
used a false bomb threat to force a
plane to land
to arrest a journalist that's the front
page of the metro financial times
leading with the chancellor's plans to
block
some companies from listing on the
london stock exchange
on national security grounds over dirty
money concerns
more papers still to come in we will
check those out as soon as they arrive
let's get the thoughts there initially
from christopher hope and allison morris
welcome
and welcome again to both of you and uh
starting with
the daily telegraph um christopher you
might as well kick this off then
uh they use the word farce for the
latest
advice for these areas hit by the indian
variant
it does seem extraordinary doesn't it
we've been so we through so many ups and
downs with these lock downs
and yet how much has the government
really learned this is guidance that
appeared
late last week urging 1.7 million people
in eight parts of england
to restrict their travel in and out of
the area in
in the northwest of of of england and
yet
um this information was only really seen
by somebody on monday
and by tuesday it looks like the
government's overruling it
will update the guidance and make sure
it's only guidance and not actually any
kind of actual
physical restrictions we're so used and
tired of these
different rules coming i do hope that
when finally get out of this mess
there'll be a degree of understanding of
the misery it can inflict on so many
people yes indeed but
the problem now i suppose alison is that
the denial of local lockdown
is a stronger message than if you're in
these areas please
take care so it really has backfired
hasn't it
it is because it was only gains these
aren't new restrictions you know this is
asking people to use common sense it's
not as if people want to be
you know fine for breaking these
restrictions but i think that the
problem is that last summer
we came out of the the restrictions and
i think we all have quite a relax
somewhere
and then in the autumn we know that we
have like a huge a huge segment wave
i think that this sort of game changer
there is a vaccine and we're hoping that
we don't go back into that
but the mixed message in from from
government i think has been
pretty clear during this period and that
is not just the westminster government
as you know the four nations
have taken their own approach and in
northern ireland we have had the
talk shows this week have been full of
people who are completely confused
and baffled as to what is restrictions
what is guidance what they should be
doing what they shouldn't be doing
and a lot of this is to do the travel
because we're looking at bank holiday
travel
we're looking at you know one minister
saying don't travel at all unless it's
necessary
another minister is trying to promote
local travel and saying
they're gonna you know put put new
measures in place to help the hotel
industry tran
pick up business over the summer months
so there's conflicting messages coming
out and that just confuses people
and i maintain if you went down into a
busy street anywhere either in northern
ireland scotland wales or england and
stopped 100 people
you would be lucky to find two who could
explain to you what the current
regulations are
and this also to me allison is a classic
case of why tall knows best
but we're reporting the telegraph that
the decision was made by the department
of health
and then no one told local leaders on
the ground i mean
it's ridiculous it's a classic case all
right yeah dry time
yeah absolutely and and it's it is once
again another example if you drill down
to the detail
then it matters christopher um it sounds
quite sensible that if you're in these
areas
please try and socialize outside it
makes perfect sense doesn't it
and then someone comes along and says
what about my wedding that's in that
area
and do i let out my holiday home for
half term next week and
it it gets very confusing very quickly
it's because anna all our lives are
complicated and different and we're all
individual thank goodness
um as uh as monty python once said we
are all individual and different
and that's why and that's why you can't
really have rules from government to
apply on lives i mean the sooner that we
can go back to a degree of common sense
i thought we went there on may 17th when
boris johnson said
you can hug someone but be careful i
think the idea of just being careful
is the new watchword from the government
but when we have these rules coming out
and no one's told
um what's an utter cock-up and i really
hope this is the last time we see this
in this pandemic
yeah let's move on to the uh the more
optimistic news which is in the
times which is this idea that the next
two weeks will be a great vaccine blitz
and the
age ranges will come down that all over
30s will be offered the jabs i know that
um in wales they've got as far as the
over 18's haven't they how's northern
ireland doing at the moment
on this one alison yeah really well
at this point in time over 25s can book
online to have a half their job
and that's turned into something of you
know quite a day out to people are
almost
organizing along with myths to go and
get their their jobs at the same time
and hilariously the the odyssey arena
which was you know the big concert venue
in belfast that's being used as a
vaccination center
and someone has noted that the music has
changed depending on the
genre of people who are being vaccinated
and so since it was the 50s
the over 50s the over 40s and now it's
over 20s
the music apparently is changing
according to generations so it's almost
like getting out to your concert going
to get your your vaccination
okay what's your favorite music are you
i i can't say much one of those groups i
fall into it well to say that i'm double
jab at this point which sort of ages me
really doesn't
yeah never ask the woman her age isn't
that isn't that the rule
uh i'm still waiting for my second
decision
i mean this is where it's going i mean
what's happening is the government is in
a race against time
against this indian variant as it's
known but the b161 7.2 as we should call
it
um it's a real it's real urgency to get
these these jobs done
i reported for the sunday telegraph just
eight days ago they're looking to hit
one million a day and that is the target
i've been told by senior figures in
government
they're going to go to 800 000 very
shortly
they want to nudge towards a million and
that'll mean that they might get
to giving everyone first jabs by the end
of next month which will be
extraordinary and that
i i expect that's where the government's
going that when they reopen
finally on june 21st most adults will be
jabbed and what a moment that will be
the street partners will be huge anna
absolutely the question is what we can
do about it um i know that was something
your paper discussed yesterday
is you know at what point they decide
that actually being vaccinated brings
some liberty
and and is this sort of june the 21st
moment or do we
do we just wait and see christopher what
do you reckon
well i i think we have to wait until
june 21st but not a moment or second
longer this is not what
boris johnson came into government to do
he's a freedom-loving
tory even matt hancock told me he was a
freedom-loving tory well
start showing it is what tories and what
maybe a lot of the country might say to
the government start
showing that actually they trust people
to live their own lives and
and you know i think it's it's looking
very upbeat at the moment and i think um
you've got the contrast of the news our
splash in the telegraph
against what people are feeling i mean
people are basically they're over these
lockdowns they're over the restrictions
they are embracing life out there in the
real world and the times
splash is reflecting that that's where
everyone's going they don't hear about
these
this chaos about when to lock down when
not locked down and i hope that's over
with
yeah i'll tell you what i'm over it's
the weather it's gonna get better though
apparently isn't it
we'll look at that bit later on um we
will discuss lots more in the next half
of our program including the appearance
tomorrow
of dominic cummings before mps plus
boris johnson vowing to take on the dog
nappers
with tougher prison sentences back in
just a moment
welcome back you're watching the press
preview with me now christopher hope
and alison morris welcome back to both
of you let's turn our attention to
something that's
happening on wednesday as i'm sure you
both know um
top of the daily mail it says
the prime minister wanted to be infected
with covid
on live tv and called the virus
kung flu revealed the grenades cummings
will launch
today uh that being tomorrow for us
right now of course uh inside the times
cummings the prime minister said kovid
only kills
80 year olds alison this is going to be
an uncomfortable day for downing street
you think
look it is and let's not pretend we all
won't be
glued to what dominique cummings is
going to say but i think that we also
need to remember
that he was part of government he was at
the heart of government
when these decisions were being made and
he's not some gallant whistleblower he's
commended sort of blow the lid
on the government this is someone who
has had a fairly nasty fallout with his
former boss
and as you said is ready to start
throwing grenades i think one
commentator said dominic cummings is the
type of man that brings a possibility
and i fight
and that's what we're all expecting
we're expecting fireworks
tomorrow what i would say is you know as
a crime reporter i have covered many
trials
where they've had people they call
assisting offenders and usually when
someone is complicit
in something whether it be working in
government or anything else
and they're given evidence against
someone who they used to be associated
with
they tend to downplay their role in
something and not play somebody else's
so i think that we need to remember that
family cummings was an advisor to the
government at this time
that any decisions that were made he
can't just wash his hands of them
but also i mean as journalists and even
i'm sure
most members of the public will be glued
to hear exactly what has said
you know this is a man who knows where
the bodies are buried and he seems to
have kept the receipts
um and we'll all be glued to see exactly
what it is he's going to do
on boris johnson who must i think he's
going to have a fairly
uncomfortable in sleep tonight one of
the most
powerful advisors you might say there
has been many people
uh there christopher saying nobody cares
about looking backwards right now it's
about
it's about the vaccine and planning the
trip to the pub for the first time and
all that sort of stuff
but here we are yet again with the real
confusion over whether or not there's a
local lockdown in areas hit by the
indian variant
whether or not you can fly to an amber
uh country
or not we're still in this short-term
messy decision-making it's as if the
lessons haven't been learned by this
government that dominic cummins is
complaining about
yes i mean there's lots of i mean i
wonder this might be not cummings his
last stand
tomorrow but it's certainly going to be
you know the last
time we're going to listen to him
closely i think because he's going to
get
all of his chests he's been tweeting
since saturday 40 strong
little um postings on social media about
what he's going to say tomorrow i mean
he's loving
um you know playing the press i mean um
i would look at look at the times i mean
they put the cummings preview inside on
page seven the front page
is as we said discussed before the break
is all about releasing lockdown and i
think in many ways
this is looking backwards to what the pm
may have said um it
only kills 80 year olds well it's not
quite true but certainly
those over age you're more at risk and
um this story next door to the story is
a poor guy called bill shakespeare the
first guy getting to get his jab
the times has now died um aged 81. so
you know this is we know about this this
virus i mean i think people
uh as seen by all the opinion polls and
also
in the by-election recently in
hartlepool they understand this is a a
novel virus an unknown killer an unknown
way of
coping with it certainly last year um
and i think people understand
and actually forgive the pierre quite a
lot i think
yes i suppose that that sort of remains
to be seen because
we all knew about it from january and
the word from
uh mr cummings was that you know even
two weeks before the actual lockdown
there wasn't even a lockdown plan so it
wasn't about waiting for the right time
to
have a lockdown it's just they hadn't
even thought about it so you know i
don't know
i don't know how forgiving people will
really feel about it
well i'm only going on the polls and i'm
only going the fact that the recent poll
forecasts the pm getting 122's deep
majority
up a third on 2019 they're certainly not
willing
it may be you may well be right when we
start going through the
line-by-line approach in those key weeks
last year in this
official inquiry that starts next year
then it may all come back and
and bite the pm in the government but
currently it's not cutting through and
people just want to get
past this but i do i do and there are
mistakes made there's no question issues
issues um with this lockdown but
you're not seeing out out there in in
the polling at the moment that's my
point
okay um alison we've only got a minute
or so left um do you want to pick the
story that you want to go to you've got
dog napping
tory islamophobia or the national trust
chairman quits
all the things we should have told you
about so far in this uh in this
programme
alison i don't know let's have a bit of
dog nothing shall we just to
really mix it up right front page of the
timeline
and this is this is a case of you know
when they say don't you know
government comes out and throws a dead
cat on the table in this case forrest
johnson appears to be throwing a live
dog
on the table as a distraction tactic for
what's
going on tomorrow so johnson's talking
about changing the the sentences for
people who
dog nappers to increase the sentences to
make it more of a deterrent i'm sure
this is something he probably does feel
quite strongly about but
it is a case of you know a good news
story on a day when there's likely to be
a lot of bad news around for the
government